les cherry hill et 21h13 et à
j'ai quelque chose à vous dire avant de
faire retentir la marseillaise comme
dire ce qui va se passer pour nous
ouvrir merci bien sûr tous les
chroniqueurs cette année magnifique de
remercier tous les intervenants mon
fabrice e j ce qu'ils sont ils ont pu
venir tous les médecins qui sont venus
tous les intervenants qui sont venus
dans tpm paix qui ont fait que c'est une
année historique pour nous en termes
d'audience merci bien sûr à tous les
techniciens toutes les personnes qui
travaillent avec moi que j'aime fort ils
le savent et qui font un travail
exceptionnel les réalisateurs tout le
monde en régie toutes mes équipes bien
entendu qu'ils travaillaient que moi
tous les jours enfin qui travaillent et
qui que je regarde travailler tous les
équipes de touche pas à mon poste bien
entendu mon cas combes était au ph
nourdine bien entendu qui est toujours
dans mon oreille mais qu'ils soient dans
mon oreille qu'ailleurs ça va pas et
bien sûr tous les auteurs fabien lettre
max voilà une pendule et tous les autres
bien entendu qui ont été fait un travail
exceptionnel léa voilà tout le monde
toutes les routes ou les maquilleurs
tous les coiffeurs oui selon l'asti
seconde est une styliste aussi mon
valentin bien entendu et et thomas voilà
est vraiment voilà tous les gens qui
nous font beau et c'est vrai qu'on en a
besoin
bien sûr tous les gens de la chaîne
c'est bien sûr je remercie mon maxime
saada
montfranc capitaux mangera de brice
viret d'amour j'espère qu'il va vite se
rétablir mon vin sans pujol alexandre
israël pauline et toute l'équipe
et bientôt je vais vous dire ce qui va
se passer
et pour l'instant je vais remercier or
une personne de marc simon lionel ce
talent d'acteur général et mon loïc qui
est toujours là avec moi depuis des
années
chérie
[Musique]
chers compatriotes
au nom de clôturer la deuxième saison ne
touche pas à mon poste sur ses buts une
saison riche en émotions riche en
rebondissements
et riche en audience les audiences n'ont
jamais été aussi haute donc merci à vous
et il est temps maintenant de se tourner
vers l'avenir
que va-t-il se passer
sachez
qu'il ya énormément de choses
ont été proposés était dans les tuyaux
et je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
que touche pas à mon poste
et
ma personne
seront
sur ces 8
pour la saison
2010 22 2023
mais également pour la saison 2009 1,3
mais également pour la saison
2003 et également pour la cedh en
merci
canal+ pour la confiance on accroît
d'accord merci à mon stéphane courbit
mon associé aux vacuum fort et hammonds
stéphane hasbanian que j'aime fort mon
avocat sachez que tout est réglé je
remercie et bien sûr toutes les
personnes du groupe donc mon maxime
saada qui a fait énormément jaser face -
yannick vincent d'amour aussi voilà
merci à vous sachez qu'on sera sur
l'antenne de chérie quatre ans en direct
lp il a bien d'autres projets jusqu'en
2026 voilà
[Musique]
je vous en remercie vraiment je vous en
remercie et j'ai peut-être mais des gens
mais voilà sébastien bardot fabrice
cloux cas voilà qui font le travail
magnifique et toutes les personnes qui
travaillent un vrai qui ont travaillé
pour moi de remercier si les personnes
qui ont fait face à bah flory et
valentin parce que c'est un énorme
succès face à baba et tous les gens qui
sont venus dans cette émission les
attachés de presse qui nous font venir
les invités qui nous font venir tous les
intervenants qui ont fait l'actualité je
suis très très très heureux d'être avec
vous jusqu'en 2026 vous m'avez apporté
énormément de bonheur ça chez lui encore
cette année et on écoutera toujours
qu'une seule personne parce que vous ne
former qu'une seule de l'espagne pour
nous c'est vous le public et vous voyez
je prends toujours en compte ce que vous
dites sur les réseaux ou sur ce que vous
pouvez me dire dans dans la rue voilà
pour essayer de faire la meilleure
émission possible on essaiera de faire
la meilleure émission possible encore
l'année prochaine avec toute la bande et
on sera de retour dès le 29 août pour
quatre années supplémentaires
[Applaudissements]
c'est honteux